PROFESSOR: So now let's add
to our theory ways
in which droplets
can be removed,
or infectious virions
within the room in addition
to ventilation and filtration
effects that we've
already described.
So the primary
way that can occur
is simply by settling
of the droplets.
So we've already talked
about the Stokes settling
speed, which scales as the
radius of the droplets squared.
So basically, larger
droplets fall fairly quickly.
And in fact, we've
already discussed
how they can fall to the
ground in a fairly short time.
It could be on the
order of minutes or less
for large droplets,
such as those
which are spewing out of
your throat when you cough
or when you sneeze--
out of your nose.
But also, the smaller
aerosol droplets
we've already
calculated can stay
in the air for a very long time.
So they settle much more slowly,
but they do still settle.
So we can try to see
how this enters in.
And the second topic
is also deactivation.
We've mentioned that the
virus doesn't live forever.
So the virions in these droplets
do need to find a target
and get out of those droplets
and into some healthy tissue
to infect it within a
certain period of time.
So there's a notion of
a viral deactivation
rate which can also be a
parameter in our models.
So if we now add those two
effects to our existing model--
I'll just keep rewriting
our mass balance equation.
And this is the mass balance
for the concentration
of virions in the air.
I've also used the terminology
in chemical engineering.
We're going to call this kind
of approximation the CSTR,
or the continuously stirred-tank
reactor approximation.
And now with all the
effects we're including,
it's starting to look more like
actual modeling of chemical
reactors and chemical
plants by this method.
So the mass balance tells me
that the volume of the room
times dc/dt--
or again, c is the
virion concentration
per volume in the air--
is the production
rate, P, minus--
and then we have a
flux, which is the flow
rate times the concentration.
And there are several
flow rates here.
There's Q, which is ventilation.
There is filtration,
which is PF QF.
And then we have now
a new term, which
I'll write in another color--
plus vsA.
So that's the settling here.
So that idea is, in
a well-mixed room,
there is a complex flow profile
which is leading to the mixing
by convection of the air.
And you might say, well, OK.
That flow is very quickly
carrying the particles up,
carrying them down--
but on average, the particles
go down just as much
as they go up.
And if it's well-mixed, then
the particles essentially
are sampling the whole space.
And relative to that well-mixed
flow, which averages to 0,
they are slowly settling.
And so a reasonable
approximation is to say,
well, the removal is
basically happening
with a flux rate, which is
that velocity of falling times
the area.
That's how quickly
those particles
are falling through
any horizontal surfaces
make relative to their average
0 motion from convective mixing.
So this is the new
effect of sedimentation.
And then actually, I will also
add to that another new term,
which is the deactivation.
And so here, we will also add
lambda v times the volume.
So this is just saying that
throughout the whole volume
of the room, there is a rate
at which every virion is
just slowly deactivating.
That will be lambda
v. Also, if you
have any volumetric
treatments of the air,
such as chemical disinfectants
or even UV light,
that may also slowly deactivate
the virus or the virions
in the air with a term
that goes like this.
So I'll just mention
that maybe briefly here.
So lambda v is the
virion deactivation rate.
And well, if we look
at tv which we've
talked about before,
which is lambda v inverse,
this is the deactivation time.
This thing has been
measured to be of order
of 1 hour in some studies.
But also , even greater than 16
hours in aerosol form in other
studies for SARS-CoV-2.
So it could be potentially long.
Also, this could include
effects such as I mentioned--
UV light treatments,
which might be operating
in a certain part of the room,
but then the air circulates
and we're essentially treating a
significant part of the volume.
It could also be
chemical disinfectants.
So there are various
chemicals that
can be sprayed in the air which
are believed to essentially
kill the virus or
deactivate the virions,
although they may cause
other harmful effects,
and so it's not so widely used.
But in principle,
that would also
appear in our simple model,
lumped into lambda v.
So let's put all these
effects together now.
So again, we haven't really
changed the calculation much.
We're just building it up
and making it a little more
complicated each time.
So let's see here.
So one thing we did
with this equation
is we divided both
sides by v. And so let
me write this equation
again after such a division.
That would be
dc/dt is equal to--
well there's P/v. But
then we have over here--
Q/v is our lambda.
But notice, all these
things are essentially
giving us a correction to
lambda, the relaxation time.
And actually, I should
say this is a minus sign.
So we get minus lambda.
And I'll say lambda c, just
for the relaxation rate
of the concentration field.
So we can lump all
these parameters
and we can write lambda c is--
Well, from the first
one, Q/v is lambda a.
That's the air change
rate of outdoor fresh air.
There is PF lambda F, which is
the rate of filtration times
the filtration efficiency, PF.
And then we have another term
which we can write as-- well,
we have lambda v.
That's an easy one.
And then the sedimentation
term is the one
I want to focus on right now.
That is vs. We can write it as
vs/h, where I've divided by v
and I'm writing v/a is h.
So I'm writing h equals v/a.
So if we have a
rectangular box of a room,
then h is the ceiling height.
But this is some kind of
effective ceiling height
if it's not a perfect box shape.
But if you take the volume
and divide by the projected
area of horizontal
surfaces, then that's
giving you a sense of
the typical height.
And that's the typical
distance by which
particles have to fall.
And notice, velocity
is distance per time.
So when I do vs,
and divide by h I
am getting something with
units of inverse time.
So it's just like all
the other lambdas.
It is basically a rate--
something per time.
So this is the concentration
relaxation rate.
I guess it would be the
theory on concentration
in the air, which is relaxing
at this rate, lambda c.
And then we come back to
solving the same simple order
of differential equation
that we've done all along.
And the solution's just c
of t is a steady state value
times 1 minus e to
the minus lambda ct,
assuming that this thing is
a constant for the moment.
And also, we know that the
cs is p over v lambda c.
So basically, if
lambda c is high,
if all these removal rates are
high, then that makes cs low.
So the background
concentration of the room
is much smaller if these
lambda rates are all high.
Also, if the lambda
rates are high,
then the relaxation
is very fast,
so you very quickly
get to the final value.
And so that's actually worth
sketching what that looks like.
So if I plot what is the
concentration, c, as a function
of time, we have
here this lambda c
inverse is the overall
concentration relaxation time.
So it looks like an exponential
relaxation to a value cs.
But I just want to
emphasize what I just
said verbally, looking
at these equations,
is that as I vary lambda c--
so if I have a fast relaxation.
Let's say lambda c
is a large value.
Then I start out
at the same rate,
but I saturate a lot faster
and at a lower value.
So if it's here, this
is fast lambda c.
So now if I increase lambda
c relative to the blue curve,
the whole thing comes down.
But also, it relaxes
more quickly.
On the other hand, if
I have slow relaxation,
because any of these
processes here are slow,
then I get something which
relaxes much more slowly
and ends up at a higher value.
So if someone is breathing
infectious air out,
exhaling, the infected
person, and there's
only very slow processes
in the room which
are removing that
infectious air,
then it's slow to
build up, but it
keeps building and building
and building until it finally
saturates.
So this is basically,
whenever lambda
c, is not a large
value or slower,
you have a slow process, but
it also builds up a lot higher.
So this effect of lambda_c is
very important to keep in mind,
especially because
these parameters here
are not necessarily constants.
In particular, v_S has a very
strong dependence on size.
So these different kind
of saturation curves
are, at the very least,
dependent on the size
of the droplets that
we're talking about.
And there's not just one size,
so we will come to that point.